are we're live good morning good
afternoon good evening wherever the hell
you are in the world and welcome to Sid
Trek and the Sol one sci-fi
podcast yeah mainly Sid Trek though
because you know like we're just the
we're just the better Channel I mean I
don't want to use I've got more
subscribers but yeah I know I I love
your channel I've always listen right
I'm saying this to my channel right I'm
always going to J at Sid Trek and all
your Co co-host everything for all the
information about Star Trek Stargate and
um yeah so if if you're if you're
watching live on my channel check out
his stuff he's got some great material I
will say though that that yeah that Mike
has got like 100 plus thousand
subscribers so and that's the dream
that's the
1566 not that I'm actually being
specific exactly exact yeah I even got
so so we are here because we are talking
about the search for spark I Dro my pen
um we have been rating all of the Star
Trek movies we have done the motion
picture we have done the wrath of KH we
have we are now going to do the Search
for Spock the what I should say is it's
the Spock lost his brain again he does
that a lot it's like it's it does it at
least
twice Katra his Katra it's Katra
yeah as as it all happens so we have
seven
ratings we have the Kirk rating we have
the check off rating oh the Kirk rating
is for Action Baby
that's right we have the check off
rating we have the Spock rating for how
logical we have the check off rating for
like morals and is it is it star treky
we have the the bones rating for is it
funny um we have the bone the the Scotty
rating for the
technology and the science behind things
we have the huru rating for how well
it's written and we have the seven of
nine rating for how good it looks
because seven of line looks so good so I
think um the motion picture I scored
2.57 out of five on the
rodenborn rating and the wrath of khah
which a movie many people consider to be
the best of all the original movies ice
go well we both scored it 3.85 on the
Roden rating so pretty high but not you
know like um yep and we're now going to
find out how the Search for Spock rates
I watched the search of Spock yesterday
for the time
years and my God I oh good oh it was it
is a great
film it is really really good hey Dave
hey Sarah hey AR brain power is doing
this um I this this chap is over on your
channel oh he's on mine yeah it's on
mine yep hello at life um hello sir uh
Laura's in hello
so right we'll kick straight off with
the Kirk rating and the
action
um we'll talk about it and then we'll
score it
but oh it's the thing I loved about two
definitely Star Trek two and three was
that they were written together sort of
thing they were planned together um yes
they were continued like a part one part
two yeah Michael wash yeah so um and I
think the the Voyage Home was as well
they were produced as a Trilogy almost
um sure the action
doesn't doesn't let you down in this
movie
um what are your what's your thinking
about having having watched it for the
first time in a while um I to be honest
I didn't watch it again but I know the
movie so well that I can already answer
without actually re rewatching it um one
aspect which I liked in comparison to
the previous movie is that um obviously
KH and Kirk in the previous movie they
didn't actually physically uh meet they
were just talking on view screens this
time we saw crug and Kirk and they had a
proper fight fist fight on a planet
disintegrating which I loved brilliant
sees of that and of course you can't go
wrong Christopher Lloyd and there was
lots of Space Battles and there on birds
of prey decloaking we had the birth Gren
blowing up we had the excelsia chasing
the enterprise we had lots of stuff um
and I I think it works very well for
Action I love the Excel ship one my
favorite ships absolutely love it
and that would then be knocking around
for the next
Century as the Frontline vessels not
just because they had a model that they
could blow up no it was actually that
successful a vessel that it was um it
survived that long
something like that yeah every time they
needed to blow up ship they just blew up
an Excel but um yeah I thought this this
had um there's not we were a bit weak on
the space battle side of things in this
movie compared to the rathan which had
one of the greatest um chess match
there's less less Space Battles in this
one a bit yeah um but we had a bit more
um well we had a bit more fisy cuffs we
had a bit more we had a a villain in
Christopher's um was it Krug crud crud
CR Krug I think it's
CR um in it's Christopher Lloyd not
Christopher ree yeah christop
Christopher ree Superman Superman yeah
that's the crossover we all wanted well
that would have been an interesting
movie yeah yeah Target Superman with
phases Mr Scotty
um I but but yeah but we had a bit more
physicality um Christopher Reef I'm
going with it now screw it was was um no
Christopher Lloyd was just as good a
villain to for me as KH um I agree I
agree um he was very uh motivated to get
the Genesis details for his own ends um
and of course um I mean yeah obviously
this film is gonna lots of spoilers
we're going to talk about but of course
um kug kills Kirk's son and uh Kirk in
turn kills his crew so there's a lot of
aspects about the fact that hates Kirk
um in a similar way to K is just he's
he's a proper cling on the only other
time the first proper cling on we
saw it's like the original gr um and
they they fires and it it destroys the
and and Christopher Lloyd goes I told
you to Target the engines and then just
shot blows and he just it's just that
really cool effect when we talk about
visuals
and his mouth and you such a cool effect
um and then and he just goes a lucky
shot my you know and it's just he's a
proper cling on Commander you know and
it's just like and I love that about it
um and and that that that he sees the
Genesis device that the Federation seees
this tool to create life but he sees it
for what it really is the greatest
weapon ever been created absolutely one
hit you know Planet Killer you know um
it just wipe everything out um hey
Freddy how you doing um so yeah I loved
it from that point of view so let's
score it from a Kirk rating then I'm I'm
gonna say we both
scored um The Wrath of Khan well you
actually scored the wrath of KH for on
the Kirk rating I scored it
five I can't say it's as as good on the
Kirk rating as the wrath of KH it
doesn't have quite the same action for
me but I'm giving it a solid four it's
really not far
off um I I agree um I'll probably give
it can we give half points or is it
going to be um like four got be let's
give it three let's give it a three from
me I'll give it a three I
think because it's it's still it is up
there with one of the movies um I mean
the whole point of this is we're rating
the Star Trek movies compared to each
other but it's really hard to split
these two films up I think really
because because they were made virtually
back to
back um it's just yeah anyway let's move
on it's like a two-parter isn't it it's
like a
yeah yeah um we'll talk about the Spock
rating because this is interesting again
because we've got the logic how
logical is um thing and we talked a lot
about the Genesis device in the last
episode and how logical it would be for
the Federation to design such a
technology for me this then goes into
though my main issue with the the device
that it is a weapon
but then they kind of the film creators
though completely flip this on its head
because they go yeah it's a weapon and
the Klingons would freaking love it um
so for me from a logic point of view
100% yeah that's what the Klingons would
see yeah but you see with the Klingons
it's a logical um aspect to in two ways
it's also logical for their benefit if
they had that they could use it as a
weapon but also they could see it as as
a weapon to themselves as an antagon as
a something which can actually affect
them so um it's it's pros and cons both
ways it's it's it's deadly if you're uh
if it's if it's something you have or
it's something that you could be on the
receiving end of so yeah logically um
greetings humans it's not just that it's
a weapon to the cling gon is it it's a
the growth and the expansion of the
Federation because I mean Christopher
Lloyd again he's talking about is and he
says oh you know we've got a nice planet
with trees and things and family you
know playing on the grass and fluttering
in the breeze is the flag of the
Federation exactly so it's not just a a
a threat it's an ideological threat to
the CL expansion expansion yeah
Federation against yeah yeah exactly
yeah um breathing groom Hitler 1939 I
know um but but yeah for me that was
Chris lyd and and and Cruz just just
explained it beautifully in that I have
one
logical area that I'm not sure and it's
really
is I'm being
nitpicky a little bit nothing wrong with
that but you know how I like to be
nitpicky that's fine
so at the end of the um Wrath of KH
obviously Spock goes into the chamber
and he does that and we got that one of
the greatest moments in sci-fi the needs
of the many you will and always be of
you yes my
friend so been repeated many times even
in Star
Trek they then put um Spock's body in a
torpedo now it would have been
radioactive is the only thing that I can
think of but they never mentioned why
they did this but they then launched
that torpedo um at the Gen his planet
and bury him they do that's the end of
it yeah when they come home Spock's dad
is like my son died he's pissed off he's
pissed off yeah my son died and I'd be
like where's his body and I'm we we we
left it on the Genesis Planet like why
just this all happened yeah well it was
the moment when and it's like
Earth we'd quite like to bury him on
Vulcan if you don't mind thank you very
much give me his body never mind the
whole you know um brain and anything
which we'll talk about the logic of that
in a minute as well because apparently V
this movie suddenly are don't die
apparently
um it made no sense to me that that they
would that they would do a burial at
se in space yeah it's it's kind of thing
I suppose that maybe Kirk thought that
the only well no and his mother was
still alive as well and I just don't
think he gave a [__] basically just
thought yeah what the hell let's just
put him on Genesis that's where you know
Genesis was created because of Spock's
death kind of thing so as you say so
that the movie could happen that's why
they did it oh yeah it's obviously it's
it's a plot
twist yeah otherwise he would have gone
to Vulcan he would have been he he would
have his Catra would have been
transferred over but that's in the spot
and of course it was a plot device but
yeah I can see what you're coming from
you my next question is this is I think
this is a little less Nick piy I think
that was Nick my next one is um have you
got a bit of a cold sir are you a bit
bunged up I have I do apologize I'm a
bit stuffed up so I I'm pling on I'm
fine sorry we're all we're all a bit
bonged up at the moment um I've just got
over a cough that I had for like a month
but anyway um so um my next question is
you've got the Katra
um if they hadn't have got Spock's body
where were they going to put
it this capure so his
brain he thought his brain was
in
Kirk the body is De would there be would
there be a possibility the Vulcan has
something where Vulcans who they can
volunt volun volunteer to take a ceased
Vulcans
CRA but then why would they do that why
would they do that no you need like um
like a blank you basically need what
they got you basically need a blank
Spock Spock which they got got movie
again it's very convenient isn't it it
worked out perfect yeah yeah yeah agree
so the whole thing and and obviously
they never mention this again in Star
Trek that I'm aware of ever that
actually when a Vulcan dies they
transfer their Spirit into another being
so it could be carried to the steps but
they don't actually then tell us what
don't
they don't they do that in Enterprise
when we have sux Catra transferred into
um uh
to yeah there was something
about time to be honest so I don't
really yeah it was used in that it was
used in that yeah it was a long time ago
but the capture of s of
um Surak the founder of the Vulcan
philosophy was being kept somehow that's
a long time since seen the episode but
that's the only time it's mentioned in
Cannon I can think of but apparently
Vulcans are Immortal um but we just
don't know the mechanics of
it then all right but if that's the case
then how come we haven't seen any more
apart from this Enterprise reference
I've mentioned it's never been mentioned
before that it's part of the culture
that a a soul if that's what you want to
consider it is is is transferred and
then what happens if um yeah they need
to explain that it wasn't actually
explained at all and it's it's funny I
never I never really thought about that
but that's a bigit bit of a big plot
hole actually in the whole Vulcan
philosophy in in this movie so
yeah explanation interesting plot device
for the movie to happen but then then it
was never really followed through at all
um and doesn't matter because it's a
brilliant film I'm just but but if we're
going to look at this from a purely
logical point of view it's a bit of a
hole in the plot you know um so I'm I'm
scoring it on a Spock
rating I'm a little I'm a
little struggling because those those
are quite big plot points but the rest
of the
movie makes sense it just makes sense um
there's the back
um they're the eles of
space Vulcans are the eles of space um
so
um if I could go half points I would
give this three and a half but we can't
so I'm giving it a three and I feel I'm
being a little mean if I'm honest but
there's just it's
the I I let me just say I would have
given it a four but you've actually made
a very valid point about the cater and
about the whole thing which has not
really been focused
upon are you thinking or have you
paused I think you've
paused so I'm on my own talking to
myself la la la la la so we have oh an
know you're back what did you what did
you decide on because you paused for a
second can you hear
me
Michael Mike okay all right I'm back I
can see you now yeah excellent so what
score did you decide on sorry three
three not that not four three three
three three baby all right then now this
is where I think we're going to score a
little higher because we've got the
check off
rating um and this r is about Star Trek
morals
Etc um I
think I well I don't think there's any
major problems in this movie for me um
there's nothing in there that I think
that's not star treky um you guys
convinced me on the Genesis weapon last
week that actually the Federation
probably would develop or would be
interested in such a technology they
abandon it because it doesn't work and
Mike is gone
what do you guys think so far about our
score rating while we're waiting for
Mike to
reappear
um I'll wait for Mike to come
back as we've got you guys in and I'm
waiting for Mike I'm going to do
something that I promised I wouldn't do
and I'm going to give you guys a bit of
an exclusive on Stargate would you like
me to do that because I can oh Mike's
back there
sorry it just chopped out it literally
just went bang something went wrong I
was gone I'm so sorry I don't know if
it's my end or your end so please what
was the last question sorry um I I was
just gonna and I was just asking the
guys in the lovely audience if they
would like me to give them a bit of a
bad new Stargate exclusive but I'm gonna
hold on to the end of the video then as
you're back but um I have got something
to to tell okay I'll look forward to it
when when you get there that's fine yeah
so the check off rating I actually think
there's nothing in this movie that's a
problem I actually think the way the
Federation behaves makes sense um the
Federation realized that the Genesis
device is a problem the only thing I
have an issue with really is that even
though when the evidence and you've got
the Vulcan Ambassador telling the
Admirals this has happened you need to
help they refuse because the genes but
that shows the politics of the
Federation as well that it is like this
hot potato um the Genesis planet in
itself is a
Nightmare and it just makes sense from
that point of view so I'm going to say a
solid four to be honest there's nothing
in it that's a problem for me okay um
well you broke up in the middle of that
but I obviously hear it again now but um
you gave it a solid four but yeah I
think in in the morals of Star Trek in
in in what's been done when it actually
fits to the proper Star Trek aesthetic
um yeah I know agreeing but I'll give it
a four as well I think it's it's got a
lot of strong points about it it fits
very well in with the whole ethos if
that's the right word for what Star
Trek's about and when people actually
make Star Trek and get Star Trek then
search for spot it's I've always rated
it very highly as you can probably tell
already so yeah I'm GNA agree with you I
say for I think it's a very solid solid
aspect on that I yeah I think I will
give you that let's go oh and this is
now next the next rating is the bones
rating and that is for humor because we
both agree that bones is just hilarious
and is I again I'm scoring this low oh
quite
High okay this might be different okay
what what's funny about it what did you
find funny about it the the early bits
in it particularly um when the bit that
I like most is when they're planning the
stealing the enterprice that's the bit
that there's four or five funny
moments um you've got the whole bit with
um the big security guard and he stands
up over Sulu and goes tin call me so
Sulu beats him up um you've got the bit
where he Kirk speaks the Admiral and
then he comes in the answer is no so I'm
going anyway um okay yeah all right yeah
yeah all right okay you've got the bit
with Ura and she picks the she picks
that job just so she can get that job
and then she pulls the phaser on the on
the guy that's had more Kirk this is
highly irregular get in the closet what
and that's really funny I love the bit
when the Enterprise is backing up
towards the space
doors and Kirk dramatically leans in and
goes Scotty now and Scotty just looks up
confused like yeah yes Captain go open
the door Scotty goes yeah I'm
trying and it carries on and then that
that moment of panic when Kur goes oh
[__] something think that whole
sequence um is just it's just hilarious
for me I just think it's it's one of the
most funny bits in Star Trek and we've
lost Mike again I'm back here you are
you are frozen I'm so sorry is it my end
or your end or what I think it's my end
probably is it it's your end um but um I
think it is guys anyway you you can tell
me if you guys can see me in the uh if
you can let me know in
the sorry so um I just think that whole
sequence is Star Trek the Original
Series at its best funny the rest of the
film isn't don't get me wrong it isn't
funny but that whole sequence is done a
little bit tongue and cheek and it's
just brilliant for me and um it's some
of the funniest bits in all of Star Trek
for me so I'm giving it a
five I I won't give it as high as that
the another funny scene I do remember
was and obviously it dropped out when
you were saying but um I was thinking
about the scene with with
bones that he's completely gone so right
a little bit of a Stargate exclusive
while Mike's gone and we'll come back to
talking about the Star Trek um uh the
the Search for Spock but oh he's now
he's back he's back I don't know this is
the worst it's ever been I'm so sorry
jay I do apologize Fair though we can
see you so whatever you just did has
fixed
it I will go on K you you say SC SC SC
SC we'll keep teasing this Stargate
exclusive but we um
I'm um and he's trying to get transport
to um the Genesis planet and he's uh
this guy sort of like argu with him and
it's it's quite funny mcco is very funny
in the scenes is it so um I think I
will you've gone again Mike
I'm I'm I think I think we're going to
have to
abandon um this video because it's it's
we're not getting anywhere with it OE
and it's not
g all right three three three okay we
got scoring we got the scoring that's
the main thing uh yeah um bones arguing
with the guy with the Big
E big be so deaf it's really brilliant
exactly yeah we will we will try to keep
get this video done
the Scotty rating is the
um yeah Jes is B loud um I love that bit
um the Scotty rating
the I give in I give in guys so I'm
going to talk about Stargate and we will
come back and we will redo this video at
some point in the future we're halfway
through I'll get mik and his Wi-Fi works
and we'll do it again because this is
one of the best Star Trek movies and it
does deserve it two things quickly um
immediately after this video I'm going
to be going over to mcbe and I'm going
to be talking to the young American we
are going to be talking about Oscars and
I am going to make him talk about
Stargate a little
bit but I have had a little bit of um
bad news about Stargate and I've spent a
couple of days now trying to find out
how real this problem
is we've given inmate but I'm going to
give you a little bit of info on
Stargate and we'll talk about that and
then we'll see how things go we'll see
if we can finish the
video but I got this exclusive a couple
of days ago um I got an email from a guy
that works over at one of the larger
talent agencies in the United States and
he's basically said he was talking to an
MGM executive about another movie um
another project that they're working on
right and while they were chatting um
they were talking about the redundancies
that were announced um and what what
they what he thought that was going to
affect um certain projects that have
been announced that they were working on
um because obviously this guy um or girl
it could be a girl um was trying to get
a feeling for the agent for for for his
employer about whether things were going
to get slowed down or
whatever um and when they were chatting
they sort of said look MGM had plans for
several big
projects um and a lot of them have been
put on hold right um so he did mention
the RoboCop movie and he said look that
that's probably on the back burner now
um it's not cancelled they still fully
intend to have a Stargate the robocock
movie but um they're going to prioritize
other things and they have to now
because there's been a significant
redundancies they will have to
restructure the
teams um the problem is that is probably
Stargate as well oh wow
so but he actually went a little bit
further with the Stargate he's actually
gone as far as saying he actually thinks
the Stargate movie is GNA get scrapped
oh what so we know because I'm not the
only one that's been saying this before
anybody jumps on saying that yeah we
know the Stargate movie was planned we
know that there's several of the actors
have come out and said
it it's you know it's last that there
was these plans for these Stargate
movies it looks like Amazon during the
strikes have decided that um there isn't
the um support that they thought they
had the the um for a movie anyway the
silver Lin might it might be the series
might actually get a more weight now it
may be you know I was talking to you
guys about August how they they had this
big meeting meeting series meeting
series MGM were arguing series and um it
may be that that they that made them go
yeah okay actually you're probably right
when they presented that evidence I
don't know for that fact I'm speculating
a bit but um the guy from MGM though
basically
was arguing U and he was actually
apparently quite annoyed says
particularly he kept using the Stargate
as a references but but he said we were
ready to go with the Stargate project
there was really good public support but
because it's dragged out so long it's
just waned there just there isn't the
support there that there
was um it's it's always interesting
because I've always thought that they
whoever's do potentially doing it they
have wasted too long it's lost its
momentum um and um the thing is that um
you know we've had Star Trek back for a
long time now we've had Star Wars back
for quite a long time with well back but
we had quite a lot of TV and they they
are trying to do stuff but everyone's
been saying and we've been saying this
on my channel for years when is Stargate
coming back and every time there's
possibility of it Brewing up and
something's
happening there's always something that
sees to St back down again into the
rubble well I mean this is one thing
after another mgm's financial problems
and then covid and then the strikes um
Amazon restructuring MGM and absorbing
MGM and now it turns out
Amazon keeps going about Amazon's Got
Deep
Pockets the problem overextended the
business apparently overextended
themselves during covid because everyone
was home everybody ordering off Amazon
so Amazon expanded very quickly and now
everyone stopped buying everything on
Amazon and all of a sudden they're like
oh the business is it doubled in size in
six months and now it's contracted they
haven't they overspent and they don't
have the finances the parent company
doesn't have the finances they did right
they're not going under or anything by
any streets of imagination but there
were some conditions that say they
actually have significant debt they
borrowed a lot of money to expand
quickly and then they contracted quickly
um yeah it's a difficult one really
isn't it it's um you know I think that
during the covid I mean you know all
these businesses we were were at home we
were watching streaming channels because
there was nothing else to do for a lot a
lot of the time and of course that some
of the companies I I feel that it went a
bit to their heads they thought well
this is this is the future this is going
to be the game and of course eventually
um normality has crept back in I mean
streaming is still a much bigger aspect
than it was um before Co yeah but it's
it's balanced out it's it's it's it went
too much one way and now it's it's
leveling out but not to the levels that
they thought it was going to be after
just this thing we keep talking about
the streaming Wars that they Netflix and
Disney the problem is streaming Wars
everybody except Netflix lost everybody
yeah apple apple did well out of it but
pretty much everyone lost but the the
thing I'm going to put a caveat on this
that this was one executive from MGM I
know what level that executive is okay
um and I can say to you that that
there's there's no reason to not believe
what they're saying but at the same time
um it's not Amazon it's not an Amazon
Source it's saying this and I've also
gone out and asked every other source I
could think of and nobody knows has
heard anything like
this the problem is there's lots of
things over the last six months that
that if this is true makes
sense MGM plus definitely definitely
want the series um the guy basically
says well look it looks like MGM plus
will get the series but it won't be this
year so mean and I don't mean it'll
appear onm this year it won't go into
going production yeah or in development
yeah okay
so and my other issue that I always come
back to in my head was I was always told
by a very um decent Source who who who
doesn't know anything specifically about
Stargate but he knows the industry okay
um and he told me well over a year ago
um that if we didn't get an announcement
on Stargate by sort of April last year
that it would be years and that we would
probably end up getting a reboot okay
um and he had a really good argument for
that at the time now that was pushed
back because we were going to get the
announcement in June which is only a
couple of months after what he said they
were gonna go San die Comic Con I know
actually for a fact that um there was a
load of prep work done and they were
going to film this at least in part in
Poland and there was a West there was a
German uh um company set up to do the
special effects and they were contract
to do the special effects I know that
was all lined up um and then obviously
the strikes happened and it got put on
pause and what did I keep say during the
strikes don't give Executives time to
stop and think about things yeah I was
to say it's about reevaluating if it's
if the momentum of um normal production
is fine then um as you say it's actually
probably beneficial thing but when
they're sitting there they can't do
anything they can't create anything you
can't anybody to write anything because
they're all on strike they H
it maybe maybe we should it's all
indecisiveness and it's kind of like
it's so frustrating
because Marvel bombing yeah Indiana
Jones
bombing um films like the Creator came
out didn't do as well I loved the
Creator great love the Creator great at
the box office it should have done it
should have done was my favorite move
from last year long as willly Wonka but
I didn't mind that I saw that you know
what that was the first film I saw at
the cinema uh since the pandemic last
thing I saw was the rise of Skywalker
and you know what it was actually a nice
film yeah I really love Jord um but I
just think that I do wonder if Amazon
have looked at that and gone a big
sci-fi franchise at the cinema we're
going to lose a crapload of
money and and I do wonder if that's the
the the bulk of it that they've they'
don't you friend and gone yeah this
isn't going to work right
now but I mean Stargate obviously
started off as a cinematic movie and
then it went to TV I mean I've always
thought that Stargate has always worked
better as a TV entity rather than a
movie franchise even though there's only
one film in that um and it's like um you
know obviously you've been reporting for
a long time sometimes you've heard that
it's more likely it's going to be a
movie and then it may be that it might
be movie which will then really go onto
a TV series and it's all this
uncertainty and it's just you know you
you are one of the biggest Stargate fans
I know and I'm a big Stargate fan myself
but it must just you know I mean you you
partly created your channel because of
being a Stargate fan and sharing it with
like-minded people I mean how do
you how does it affect you does it
really make you feel disheartened about
um streaming services in general and all
this uncertainty or you how do you sort
of put it on board and deal with it for
me it's frustrating
because I've been incredibly lucky to to
see behind the scenes and see and be
able to
hear every step almost of the and
there's there's stuff I've not been able
to tell you guys because I can't that's
understand I can understand of course
yeah understand that um and so I know a
bit more than what I can say sure um and
it's absolutely maddening how um
particularly Amazon works as a studio
right um and
then you know I've been talking about
Stargate now for two years before that
but for a long time it was because I had
sources at MGM they were telling me MGM
would being allowed to believe that they
were going to be allowed to crack on
with their project they had the Brad
right script they and they had another
script that they thought they were going
to be able to and they were they were
Amazon was going to let them do it yeah
and then a year year ago all of a sudden
it was like they're going to do a movie
Amazon want to do a movie right be
reporting that yeah that's right um and
then everyone else started reporting
it's going to be a movie certain people
like popcast guys were pretending that
they would released the exclusive it was
going to be a movie but anyway um bloody
people um but you know and then it it it
rocked on and then we they started doing
all the development work they started
doing all this thing we know that you
know and so I'm watching this happen and
I think brilliant is getting this way I
don't particularly want to mie but
brilliant it's
happening really and then around March
all of a sudden things started
unraveling and again I can see it
unraveling and it's like I I've got a
horrible feeling I know where this is
going and I've got certain people still
going to my ear you know no no don't
worry this is still gonna happen they've
already
spent I can't say but they've already
spent money on this okay okay um a lot
of money on this um um again I can't say
more than that but
it's and and then for it to go to this
point and go well it's just not going to
happen and and I I say it's not it's I
don't want to say it's definitely not
going to be a movie because Amison could
still turn around and go yeah we've
Chang you know it's it's fine but yeah
ah it's not good it's not good um you
just have to hope that um you know some
something will suddenly come along and
you come back so actually this is new
idea and it's you know I don't know I'm
just sick of tired of it I'm sick and
tired of it not getting going and I the
longer that there's a gap between
because I think um uh uh Universe
finished about 2011 I think it was it's
about like 12 12 13 years ago it's been
a long time now um and um you know in
the end um even though Stargate is a
wonderful franchise that's a long time
for to not basically have anything apart
from that um
that um this this person from MGM was
basically ran and he apparently he got
quite annoyed and he was just like we
and he wasn't just talking about
Stargate but apparently Stargate was the
because my source is interested he liked
Stargate so he kept asking about it but
um he saying we had all this brilliant
momentum we had all this brilliant um
really positive um momentum to do
several projects sure and Amazon has
come in and just completely deflated
everybody
oh Sor um because they've decided to
absorb the company basically and it's
taken forever and they had all this
opportunity to release really good
positive stories and they've just not
done it just not proceeded with it um
and I've got sources that again I work
really high up in these areas banging
their heads against a brick wall gone
why on Earth aren't they announcing this
why aren't you know telling me that when
the starget movie was planned announce
it now just announce it once you've
announced it then you've actually sort
like started off I don't know if when
they waiting for S ComiCon I don't know
if they had one eye on thinking this
might not happen because the strikes so
let's hold let's wait wait wait and then
actually the strikes happen and it
didn't and that's what yeah yeah but
they were you know just people got just
just let's just announce it now we need
a good news story let's just announce it
and and they just wouldn't they just
kept holding it it would get a huge
amount of eia hype if they' have done it
if they sort of like said you know it
would I mean the whole community
uh not just but just people in science
fiction General it's dargate is big
enough that it would actually they might
think a this has got a lot of interest
here this is actually you know maybe
maybe this is actually a good idea but
they there were too well like said the
circumstance wasn't it too long too long
anyway I'm gonna talk about this a
little bit more on the live video with
Harris so don't forget to go over and um
subscribe you want to talk about Oscars
and things but we'll talk about this a
little bit as well because Harris cried
when I told
him is he upset yeah a little bit um so
we'll finish off this rating anyway we
yeah sorry about that it's been an
interesting one with the
production we're on the Scotty
rating so we'll whip through because
I've promised yeah yeah that's fine
that's no props Scotty rating um both of
the first two movies for technology
scored threes for me
uh and you no you scored four for um you
scored higher for the last one because
you like the Genesis I I was I was kept
arguing about the practicality of the
Genesis weapon and I was going about the
technical I am going to say that I still
have an issue with the
um practicality of how a Genesis weapon
works but I love the way they set this
up to turn it into a weapon and I love
things like how um the rapid evolution
of the planet and stuff then they linked
it in with the bacteria and things I
really really like that and I'm not
going to pretend it's very
technological
but um somebody even came up with how
the transwarp drive works for the um
that's what I was going to say I was
waiting to say transwarp that was my
going to be my side of things that's my
technical aspect of this movie yeah it's
basically was um used almost like
transporter technology merged with a
Walk Drive and it didn't work but that's
how it was supposed to work there's a
whole never knew that that's been
explain the whole thing that explained
it it's marvelous really really clever
and genius um technology um so I'm going
to give it a four and it's being
generous because there's certain aspects
of the film that make no sense but I
love how well thought out and everything
was connected and um like I said the
bacteria massively evolving and
regenerating Spock cells and things like
this it it was all interl it was all
very clever and none of it sort of
contradicted anything else it was
thought
through well I I think for me
technologically I'll give it three for
the simple reason that both the
technological aspects of this movie went
wrong Genesis went wrong and also trans
warp went wrong so as far as I'm
concerned they were great technological
ideas but they in in reality they didn't
actually prove themselves to be too kind
of uh um reliable so I'm going to give
it a three I think okay for that simple
reason I actually think the next rating
is going to be the huru rating Harris I
will be with you at seven mate because I
want to eat at some point this evening
so we'll finish we'll we'll get this
done we'll get this done go yeah he's
he's there in the comments going don't
worry I'm hanging out well stop hanging
out be ready because I've got it I'm so
hungry um damn you Harris Young
Americans he's he's just had his
breakfast I need my tea but anyway Hur
rating straight up for me I'm not even
arguing this it's a five done um I think
both of these movies are beautifully
written there is I have absolutely no
issue with any of the writing it's
logical it's funny when it's supposed to
be it's heart-wrenching when it's
supposed to be you bastard you kill my
son
um it's it's perfect it's one of my
favorites I completely agree
wholeheartedly as giving you a five as
well I absolutely love to search a Spock
I I still remember seeing it uh in my
local video shop um like a blockbuster
sort of thing and I I couldn't wait to
Har it out and watch it and I loved it
and I remember seeing it when I was
about I don't know how old I was but
about 13 14 and I absolutely adored this
movie so yeah for that rating ay for me
yeah and when we talk about the next
movie it's just like this isn't this
isn't quite that but these three movies
slight
different yeah so beautifully written
and so beautifully conceptualized even
if you break down the plots of the story
they make no bloody sense at all um you
know like big cylinder comes and attacks
our
oceans Bas that's it that's it no that's
it brilliant absolutely brilliant the
seven of nine rating for visuals again
all day I'm going a five I think and we
scored both we both scored this in five
and the agree same yeah five again yeah
absolutely for the made it for the way
it looks um wonderful absolutely
wonderful production in every way shape
or form you can't for it obviously you
know a little dated is you know just
because it's stated doesn't mean it's
still not good it's it's wonderful you
know I I kind of like a lot of the old
visuals compared to the CGI fests that
you get in some Modern things which um
doesn't always work for me it does work
sometimes and quite a lot of times but
no what they did with that movie was
absolutely and the shots of the excelsia
leaving space Dock and gliding by and oh
it's wonderful the Grom and the bird of
prey clo the wi the effect of the
Enterprise going into um star Base 001
oh God yeah and when it's slowly going
into Port sort thing and the you know
nurse chaplain people there and everyone
in the bay aren't they they sort ah yeah
seeing that at the cinema though
absolutely fantastic I'd love to have
seen it the cinema it would have been
epic if I seen it up but that was
released brilliant I've just done my
score I'm just doing your
now okay plus I think this one's going
to be quite High I
think that can't be right wait a
second I must have done some math wrong
there that's do the math wrong man got
to do the math right sorry that's a
terrible
accent6 divided
my you've um scored it quite a lot lower
than me oh you've scored a couple lower
than me right okay wased about that you
yeah I've scored it slightly
lower than the Wrath of Khan which I
think probably is fair so you've scored
it at
3.71 you um you scored the WRA of K at
3.85 I've actually similar similar go on
the um this movie
4.28 so the way I have scored this is
actually better than the W of
G I like them both though I mean I if I
really have to choose I'd say that I
both like them equally but the way that
we we rate it it's it's not going to be
exact but where I what where split these
up is the bones rating for me I rated
hum a fair bit lower okay the search for
the wrath of KH a lot lower and um and I
rated um the Scotty rating I've rated a
little bit higher because I've gone with
the with the thought and that's where
the difference has been all right that's
fair enough um which is that thing as a
movie maybe yeah there's no humor in the
wrath of KH particularly whereas there's
a beautiful 10 minutes in this film is
just which I'd actually forgotten about
until you actually sort of like um
reminded me of some of those scenes
you're all right it's just a second
artist not much human yeah yeah so right
that is it we have scored so so far we
have scored I've scored the first movie
2.57 the second movie 3. 85 and the
third movie 4.28 these films are getting
better and better every time we do it
until we get to Star Trek 5 in which
case you have scored them 2.12 3.85 and
3.71 so I think most people would
probably agree with that though that
Search for Spock is not quite as iconic
as the wrath of KH so
but still a wonderful movie still a
brilliant movie and yeah absolutely fny
because then you can actually see where
it's it's an interesting experiment and
also from our different perspectives I
mean we both like Star Trek but in the
end um you know every Star Trek fan
reacts slightly different to what's out
there and what they made different
aspects of theie from discovery of
course so most people sort respond to
Discovery and that
like the first
um I like the second season the first
season makes me
angry um irrationally violent towards um
Klingons um made out of plasticine but
um but other than that it's a great yeah
I hate I was gonna say other than that
it's great it's not it's awful I hate
Discovery um other than Michelle yo I
hate discovering it's terrible and just
as the video gets towards the end
Mike freezes again this happens every
bloody week okay J I'm back you need to
get some
better um uh can I suggest not getting
my Wi-Fi provider though because it's
bloody awful but um but um it's better
you live do you live near the coast or
something do you live you somewhere you
live somewhere quite pretty don't
you you can't hear me I'm completely
gone all right then well there is a
link there there is a link to our
Mikey's Channel Co clud in the
description please and subscribe and
likewise a like way to Sid Trek on on
all stuff you do all B bril yeah yeah it
is it is one of the best channels on
YouTube really Sid Trek and
um and we should all love it and cads
you know but
Sidra we all do what we do and I just do
it a little not as well as other people
but I enjoy what I do I don't do it the
same as you I just do it for a laugh you
know it's all about having fun and
sharing stuff and people like feel the
same as I well same here I do I do it
because I enjoy doing it or I wouldn't
yeah I do too I like get out there and
meet interesting people so that's why
we're no I've made some of my best
friends in in real you know through
doing this channel which is just and and
my my co-host on my channel he's a great
guy Martin so I'm I'm meeting people
like you as well it's great yeah I I
love Martin he's he's funny Martin right
come back to our Channel soon by the way
have to have you back soon yes um I may
I will accept any invite of anything
that you want to do um that I can be
bothered to attend that's great that
works for us can't really argue with
that can you I'm there 100% if I can be
asked that's fair enough that's I can't
arue with that you do something any
anytime mate honestly I if I've got the
time I will give I appreciate it thanks
so Co clud um you're well there you go
Harris said you're always a welcome on
um M3 as well if you want so I will link
you guys up um but he's gone again so
thank you so much Mike for mostly
attending this
episode and I'll see you again really
[Music]
soon byee everybody meet us over on
mcubed in about five minutes see you in
a minute bye bye guys bye